foreign
[Music]
this is Sky News at 10 live from Dublin
the US president goes back to his roots
in Ireland earlier urging the leaders in
Northern Ireland to restore power
sharing in Stormont
I believe Democratic institutions
established the Good Friday agreement
remain critical to the future of
Northern Ireland
the decision for you to make not for me
to make
[Music]
the president praises the prime
minister's brexit deal as the White
House insists he's not anti-british
also tonight on Sky News at 10 Prince
Harry will attend the king's coronation
but his wife and children will stay in
the U.S the Scottish and Westminster
governments to go to court over the
gender Reform Bill
doctors leaders call for arbitration to
help end the junior doctor's strikes
after a second day of walkouts puts more
pressure on the NHS Professor is now
starting to ramp up number of
intendencies has increased significantly
since this morning and Majors cubicles
now were occupied
and the end of the fossil age new
predictions that Renewables could
overtake fossil fuels for the first time
this year we'll test the theory
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
good evening from Dublin Ireland where
the U.S president has been visiting the
home of his ancestors just north of here
earlier Joe Biden was in Belfast where
the message was clear return power
sharing to Stormont
the Northern Ireland assembly has been
suspended for nearly a year now but the
dup has responded to the president's
please saying it doesn't change anything
politically in a moment we will get the
latest from County lab and the latest
leg of Biden's Island Tour but tonight's
first report is from our senior Island
correspondent David Blevins in Belfast
it is now my great honor to introduce
the president of the United States of
America Joe Biden foreign
he didn't have much time to spare this
was the president's only engagement in
Northern Ireland where efforts to
preserve Pace unite a polarized America
supporting the people of Northern
Ireland protecting the peace preserving
the Belfast Good Friday agreement is a
priority
for Democrats and Republicans alike in
the United States and that is unusual
today
Joe Biden had met privately with the
main political leaders before publicly
appealing for a restoration of power
sharing at Stormont
as a friend I hope it's not too
presumptuous for me to say that I
believe Democratic institutions
establishes The Good Friday agreement
remained critical to the future of
Northern Ireland it's a decision of you
to make not for me to make
but the dups already made its decision
rejecting Rishi sunak's New brexit Deal
so did the president's words change
anything well it's good to have the
president of the United States here in
Belfast we welcome him as we welcome all
visitors but I don't think it changes
the political dynamic or the reality
that what we need is the reassurance
that our place within the United Kingdom
is both respected and protected well I
mean I very much welcome the fact that
they have had such a strong commitment
to our peace process over the last 25
years and I asked him to stay at the
course with us and and very much
welcomed the fact that he has been very
young people focused on this visit that
he has been talking about Prosperity
opportunity opportunity for investment
so in the quick conversation trying to
get all those things in was my challenge
but I think I've actually did that the
Good Friday agreement has enabled a
generation to grow up in peace including
the former student who introduced him I
think today has just been a reminder of
how far we've come in the last 25 years
and now of course there is still works
today but how resilient and capable our
generation is to be able to make that
piece happen in the coming 25 years
this speech could be summed up in one
word potential the president urging
Northern Ireland's political leaders not
to miss the opportunity that exists for
significant economic investment here if
there's a stable government
there was a brief bilateral with the
Prime Minister both leaders in Belfast
marking 25 years since the historic
compromise President Biden and I spoke a
lot about that and we spoke in
particular about the incredible economic
opportunities that are there in store
for Northern Ireland and we talked about
the investment potential that is there
the companies that want to invest in
Northern Ireland I think that's
incredibly exciting or been growth jobs
and prosperity to Northern Ireland and I
know he shares my ambition to see the
institutions here back up and running
and his message to this audience could
not have been clearer when it comes to
preserving peace and restoring power
sharing in this corner of the UK America
is still in the picture David Blevins
Sky News in Belfast
well the president is exploring some of
his Irish Roots here in Ireland he
traveled from Belfast to Dublin this
afternoon where he was greeted on a
rainy Runway by the Irish Prime Minister
he then traveled to County Lao an area
where Biden has ancestral routes this
included a visit to a pub in the town of
Dundalk from there our Island
correspondent Stephen Murphy reports
after the political the personal Joe
Biden crossed the border to begin his
day of ancestral exploration in County
louth's Coulee Peninsula his ancestors
the Finnegans left the area for a new
life in America in 1839 the last major
landmark they would have seen was
carlingford castle where the president
was given a tour
as the rain poured down President Biden
arrived in Dundalk it was time for a
short Walkabout meeting local business
owners before heading to a pub somewhat
and probably called The Windsor here a
clearly relaxed president felt at home
in a sense I know why my ancestors and
many of your relatives left during the
famine
and uh but uh you know when you're here
you wonder why anyone would ever want to
leave
I mean it
so it's good to be back it was however
also the venue for the first goth of the
presidential visit paying tribute to his
distant cousin Rob Carney a former Irish
Rugby International he said this you see
this tie I have with a shamrock on it
this was given to me by one of these
guys right here it was a hell of a rugby
player and they beat that little black
and tans oh God clearly confusing New
Zealand's All Blacks for the reviled
British parliamentary Force the black
and tans which tried to brutally
suppress Irish Independence it was a
blip on a day the proud irish-american
otherwise appeared to enjoy look at this
Air Force One right here that's pretty
cool man his next round of engagements
returns to a more political theme in
Dublin meetings with the Irish Prime
Minister and president and addressing a
joint session of the Irish Parliament we
can expect his comments there to stick
more tightly to script
Stephen Murphy Sky News in County louth
joining me now from Belfast is our
political correspondent Sam Coates and
Sam how did the president's meeting with
Rishi sunak go today there was some
criticism that the president didn't
spend enough time with the Rishi sunak
yes you might look at elements of the
president's visit to the United Kingdom
and wonder about the state of relations
there was its brevity the lack of overt
enthusiasm for the Prime Minister from
the president in front of the cameras
and the fact that White House aides even
had to deny that the president is
anti-british on the flight over but
talking to all sides including critics
of both sidak and Biden it's clear that
actually they're pretty pleased with how
today went you've got to remember the
two men had different agendas President
Biden wants to appeal to the 40 million
or so Irish Americans uh by basically
having the Pomp and ceremony in the
Republic South of the Border rather than
up here in the north whereas Rishi sinak
wants to get the storm assembly Northern
Ireland and politics back up and running
and even though there was no
breakthrough I think they were pleased
that Joe Biden's speech was nuanced he
didn't roll the unionists by hectoring
them back into Power sharing he
presented an optimistic view of the
teacher the bottom line about the
relationship is that this white house
has decided is a man they can do
business with and the Pomp and ceremony
of the special relationship for the
cameras well that can wait till another
day
Sam thank you getting out of the the
rain now we've all been subject to the
rain throughout the day but it has been
a busy first day today as people in
Ireland and in Northern Ireland turned
out to get a glimpse of the president
and we do expect to see more of that
hopefully not to as much rain though but
on Thursday he'll visit the Irish
president and address the Irish
Parliament they'll also be some tree
planting and the ringing of a peace belt
and later on he'll attend a banquet back
here at Dublin castle in the evening and
his trip will conclude on Friday with a
visit to County Mayo where he's a more
distant cousins that he can make and
he'll make a public speech at a
cathedral in Ballina so another busy day
for the president he's on his way back
to Dublin as we speak back to you Emma
Jillian thank you
Palace has confirmed that the Duke of
Sussex will attend the king's coronation
but he'll do so without his wife Megan
The Duchess of Sussex and the couple's
children who will remain in California
here's our Royal correspondent Laura
bundock
this was the last time we saw them
together in the UK and ever since the
Queen's funeral speculation about the
king's coronation months of will they
won't they and now an answer Harry's
coming but Megan isn't it would have
been pretty Unthinkable
um and almost done known in history for
uh the second son not to attend the
father's coronation uh so it looks like
they've managed by hooker by crook to
actually come up uh with a solution the
Duke of Sussex will attend the
coronation service at Westminster Abbey
on May the 6th The Duchess of Sussex
will remain in California with Prince
Archie and Princess lilybert no detail
on what made up their minds
no one knows the full truth
we know the full truth but their Netflix
series Harry's book and interviews
clear there was a lot to
did as for Megan her absence is
significant it shows that there's a
willingness to compromise on the part of
the uh the Sussex couple and understand
the importance of history in that the
Royal Dukes are a really important part
of the family but I think it also means
that there's very much an independence
that's in place for Harry and Megan that
they're not really going to compromise
on at least not at present
security had always been a big issue for
the couple it's still not settled
neither is the dispute between Harry and
William but at least coming alone the
Duke of Sussex avoids some awkward
moments this is perhaps the outcome the
royal family privately hoped for there
were fears the presence of both sussexes
here would have created a media circus
distracting and diverting attention away
from the coronation the family Rift
seems far from resolved but for now the
king probably just relieved he'll have
both sons present for his crowning
moment Laura bundock Sky News
the Scottish government has confirmed
that it will seek a judicial review over
the decision by the UK government to
veto Hollywood's controversial gender
Reform Bill the bill was passed in
Scotland just before Christmas but in
January the Westminster government
decided to block it from receiving Royal
assent and becoming law our Scotland
correspondent Connor Gillis has been
looking at the implications of the two
governments going to court
yet another constitutional Clash looms
over this country the UK and Scottish
governments prepare for a showdown in
the courts
law has passed here at Hollywood making
it easier to change gender something
westminster's blocking over fears it
impacts on uk-wide equality laws we had
concerns as the UK government Secretary
of State set this out at the time
concerns about how Scotland's gender
recognition act would interact with
reserve powers about the operation of
the equalities act the protection of
women elsewhere in the UK as well the
Scottish changes speed up the existing
UK process no diagnosis of gender
dysphoria or medical reports are
required applicants must live in their
acquired gender for three months rather
than two years 16 and 17 year olds can
also apply for a gender recognition
certificate for the first time
a relief then for the trans Community to
hear the legal standoff is underway I'm
a trans man I came out about five years
ago now
um and this kind of change would have
been a lot easier had it come in a bit
earlier in the sense of having the
correct details for you know not having
to stress about it
um it should be just quite a minor
change in the scale of things we need
but it's become this huge big cultivar
and which is really not very nice to see
when people talk about you in those ways
Scotland's new first Minister hums a
Yusuf stood in the recent SMP election
battle on a ticket that not challenging
this in court would result in doubting
Street thinking it could run a coach and
horses through future devolve
legislation but as leadership rivals in
that contest said it's a pointless
exercise because legal advice was
suggesting the Scottish government would
lose so with so much taxpayer cash at
stake what is the right position to take
we have of course looked very seriously
at the points which the secretary of
state has raised within his order we've
of course Very looked at the detail of
that but what's important are you
confident that's that's the question
that I'm trying to get to here that is
up to the courts that is up to the
courts as a government are you confident
of your case well we're very confident
that we have the ability to take the
judicial regime forward the UK
government said it would not reveal its
legal advice neither side is blinking as
both prepare to ramp up the route over
reforms Conor Gillis Sky News Edinburgh
the governor of the bank of England
Andrew Bailey has said that UK Banks may
need more cash buffers to cope in the
future Following last month's banking
turmoil in the U.S he was speaking at an
international monetary fund event in
Washington well joining us live from
there is our economics and data editor
Ed Conway and the governor Ed not seeing
a repeat of the financial crisis but the
banking sector has seen stress so what
was his prognosis
yeah the governor very keen to say that
he doesn't see any kind of prospect of a
repeat of what we saw in 2008 and indeed
although we have the collapse of certain
Banks including Silicon Valley Bank most
famously here in the US and it had a UK
arm as well he thinks the broader
Financial system is in Pretty in a
pretty good State at the moment but yeah
some concern about liquidity buffers and
also perhaps you know in a sense the
most interesting thing is he also talked
about the deposit Insurance scheme that
we have in this country now if you put
money into a bank it is protected up to
85 000 pounds at the moment but he was
implying that that might be a little bit
too low and so Deposit Insurance rules
could be changed in future to make that
higher it's worth noting that here in
the US the deposit insurance and this
this is basically saying that if the
bank were to collapse this is how much
of your savings would be protected
within that bank account here it's 250
000 to give you a sense in the UK 85 000
pounds and he's his implication is that
level which was set back in kind of just
after the financial crisis so more than
a decade ago might not be high enough
and we may need to raise that so that
could be a big change for the UK
particularly given there is so much
nervousness here in Washington in the UK
as well about the state of the financial
system and about the cost of living
crisis so more talk about coming in the
future days with the IMF meeting now it
kind of more or less it's halfway point
Ed in Washington thank you
the union representing Junior doctors
has called for the health secretary to
take part in talks via the mediation
service acas it's the second day of a
four-day walkout today already resulting
in thousands of canceled appointments in
the National Health Service one senior
Doctor Who has stepped in to help out as
the strikes take place has given us an
insight into how hospitals are coping
Sky's National correspondent Tom
palmeter reports
[Applause]
the junior doctors are still out
their senior colleagues pulled in to try
and fill the gaps
one of them agreed to take us into his
day at the emergency department in
lewisham in South London the last time
we covered Virginia doctor strikes it
was incredibly busy so we'll see what
today brings this week is about
prioritizing emergency care okay so
halfway through the shift and the
pressure is now starting to ramp up
number of intendencies has increased
significantly since this morning and
Majors cubicles are now well occupied
the warnings were soon going out to
patients about delays in this trust I'm
working inside the system system is a
bit broken
um and we need to fix it if we don't pay
our staff no what they deserve for the
conditions they're working under and the
responsibilities and expectations that
they have and then then they'll just get
up on me
and then the NHS will be in any more
crisis than it is coming the Westminster
government say they want a fair deal but
the junior doctors pay demand of 35 is
unrealistic thank you patients are
caught in the middle but at least Phil
can get on with his life he volunteers
at a food bank in South London it was
his cancer checkup that was postponed by
the strike
he's dismayed that the government has
yet to negotiate I know they're going to
have to do it
I have delayed months they will delay
further months and where the people
suffer people who are in Far More
Jeopardy than I am
in loads more pain than I am loads more
anxiety than I am
everything points to this just carrying
on if the government won't come to the
table over a 96 hour walkout then
I have no frame of reference for what
happens next I would expect there to be
further action so the stress on the
system and the people within it just
builds now like most of my colleagues I
stay a little bit longer just to finish
a few things for my patients
it's been very busy this afternoon and
quite stressful the Department's full
but everybody's worked tirelessly to the
gap for our patients England is halfway
through this walkout and the pain is
starting to show
for patience and the service they pay
for and rely so much on
Tom Parmenter Sky News
the press secretary for the Kremlin
Dimitri peskov has told Sky News that
he's not surprised that NATO's special
forces are in Ukraine it's after an
apparent leak of top secret documents
circulated online the mod suggesting
that the alleged documents demonstrated
a serious level of inaccuracy there are
not questions over how the leak happened
and what harm it could cause Sky's U.S
correspondent James Matthews has this
report
the U.S pentagon or national security is
built on secret Intelligence on
adversaries and allies this leak of
sensitive documents published on social
media covers both
as the U.S defense secretary met
Ukraine's prime minister at the Pentagon
questions went unanswered
thank you no questions thank you this
can't have been their easiest meeting
[Music]
because the league documents detail U.S
training and Equipment schedules to
support Ukraine in its war with Russia
there was Intelligence on Ukraine's
President Vladimir zielinsky and talk of
Ukraine's battle for the donbash region
likely heading for a stalemate
throughout 2023
another document revealed conversations
between South Korean officials about
their reluctance around a U.S request
for ammunition to be sent to Ukraine
there's a lot of ability to digitally
track back Bradley Morse is a National
Security lawyer based in Washington the
Pentagon investigation into who leaked
what is something he's seen before if
they can figure out the original Source
documents they can then you know sort of
work backwards to track who had access
to it and who were some of the last
people to try to extract that
off-classified servers
following the league the Pentagon spoke
of a very serious risk to National
Security but it's also urged caution
with regard to the documents stating
that slides appear to have been doctored
similarly the UK's Ministry of Defense
says the documents shouldn't be taken at
face value
Ukraine is the French Minister set the
weak documents contain what he called
truths and not truths
I call it a special informational
psychological operation done on purpose
the beneficiary of this operation is of
course Russia the purpose of this
operation is to lower the level of trust
between partners the United States of
America first of all and other countries
whatever its impact on trust between the
United States and its allies the
Pentagon leak can't improve confidence
well James joins me now from Washington
real concern then James about the
underground consequences for the war in
Ukraine and concern too about a video
emerging of what appears to be the
beheading of a Ukrainian Soldier
there is indeed uh yeah there's a video
posted online it shows an individual in
a green jacket and yellow armband
typical of the Ukrainian fighter his
screams are heard before a second man in
in camouflage uses a knife to decapitate
him and then a third man holds up a
flank jacket apparently belonging to the
victim it has been widely condemned
internationally certainly in Kiev
president zielinski has demanded the
world leaders respond he's posted a
video online in which he says there is
something that no one in the world can
ignore how easily these beasts kill no
one will understand if the leaders don't
react action is required now he says the
United Nations mission that monitors
human rights in Ukraine says it's
appalled by this video Ukraine's State
security service has launched a war
crimes investigation into what it is
calling the brutal murder of a prisoner
of war it's the Mandate that the
international criminal court pursue its
own investigation also Russia for its
part says the video is horrible but has
insisted it needs to be verified
James Matthews thank you
a man has been extradited from Pakistan
and charged with murder over the killing
of pc shambreshnevsky pc bishniewski was
gunned down while responding to a
robbery at a travel agent in Bradford in
2005 as well as murder 74 year old
pirandita Khan has been charged with
multiple other offenses and will appear
at Westminster magistrates court on
Thursday
you can Ireland have submitted their
final joint bid to host the Euro 2028
Men's Football Championship if
successful it could see matches played
at Wembley the National Stadium of Wales
and the Dublin Arena
a new report has suggested the world
will use more renewable sources than
fossil fuels to produce electricity this
year for the first time ever the energy
Think Tank Ember calls it the beginning
of the end of the fossil age our data
and forensics correspondent Tom Cheshire
has been investigating if the claims are
true
it would be a watershed moment according
to the report it could already be a
watershed moment this year might be the
first to see a drop in fossil fuels used
to generate electricity the first
outside of pandemic or recession this is
the grounds for optimism you can see
wind and solar now represent 12 of total
electricity production extend that
forward according to the think tank
Ember and you'll get less fossil fuels
in the Energy Mix worldwide and that
trajectory is based on what's been
happening in solar wind all around the
world you can see some countries moving
at a quicker Pace Oceana Europe as
regions doing better but everyone more
or less on the same Journey
last year 80 of the rise in electricity
demand globally was met with wind and
solar alone so every year has been going
on when and solar have been forming a
higher and higher amount of the the
electricity that we we use incrementally
and now that's taking us towards the
Tipping Point where all of
um electricity demand grows globally is
met with clean power
so job done well no even if it is a
Tipping Point fossil fuel needs to
decline lots and needs to decline fast
clear power has been rising as a
proportion of our mix but because our
total electricity demand has also been
rising it means that fossil fuel
emissions are still going up there may
be a smaller slice of the pipe but the
pie is growing bigger so they're still
higher than ever and much of that is
because of our use of coal the most
polluting fossil fuel now there is good
news here around the world cold plants
have been shutting you see them closing
down below uh compared to opening above
that is a negative Trend that's the rest
of the world excluding one country and
that country is China and China leaves
the world in renewable energy but it
also leaves the world in core use you
can see how many more plants it's been
opening compared to how many it's been
shutting that obviously is not ideal
that makes a massive difference for
those projections we were talking about
at the start and whether the world
really will make them and across the
board for all sorts of important
measures we are behind coal needs to go
down electricity needs to go up gas
needs to go down wind and solar need to
go up massively and every one of those
you can see these projections we are a
long way behind the pathway to note zero
there is a huge amount to do
Tom Cheshire there well that was Sky
News at 10 coming up we'll take a first
look at tomorrow's newspapers in the
Press preview including this story on
the front page of the Guardian the
headline Biden pledges six billion
dollars of investment of Storm Power
sharing is restored well tonight we'll
be joined by the daily mirrors associate
editor Kevin McGuire and the sun's
political reporter Noah Hoffman
[Music]